when the original justice league hit
theaters in 2017
audiences found their fair share of
problems with it to say the least
for one there was the jumbled mishmash
of tones due to the film having two
directors
zack snyder and joss whedon each with
different visions of what the movie
should be
or how about the borderline
incomprehensible storytelling that
resulted from whedon cutting down
snyder's vision of a four-hour
epic into a two-hour cliff notes version
but none of justice league's flaws came
to embody the movie's failures quite as
well as superman's mustache
this is how it all went down when zack
snyder was at the helm during principal
photography in 2016
soup's actor henry cavill was clean
shaven when joss whedon was brought in
to direct his reshoots the following
year however cavill had already grown a
dastardly mustache for his villainous
role in mission impossible fallout
trouble was cavil was contractually
obligated to keep the mustache
fallout director christopher macquarie
later told empire that he actually did
give permission for cavill to shave
in exchange for three million dollars
from justice league's producers to cover
the costs of digitally filling in
cavill's upper lip but paramount
pictures executives balked at the
compromise and the responsibility of
henry cavill's facial hair management
fell
entirely on team justice league the
film's cgi artists did the best they
could to digitally shave him
but the end result looked well it looked
bad really
bad in the end the superman's mustache
fiasco came to symbolize the worst of
the 2017 cut of justice league and
perfectly demonstrated how all the money
in the world can cover up something that
just isn't going to work
everyone knows what happened next
justice league opened as a relative box
office flop
fans started the hashtag release the
snyder cup movement and warner media
finally gave snyder the money to release
his version of the movie on hbo max
zack snyder's justice league has
garnered a positive response too
and in recent days zack snyder has been
talking to the press about the
experience
as a whole snyder has refrained from
actually bad-mouthing the theatrical
version
but he is apparently relieved that
superman's weird cgi face doesn't
feature on the final version of the
character
asked about the mustache mishap by mtv
news snyder said that since he's never
seen whedon's version of the movie he's
never really gotten a good look at
smooth superman
he explained i've only seen it in memes
it was funny because part of me is happy
that we were able to have that not be
the total legacy of the hard work that
cavill had done over the last 10 years
you know
it's sad to think that could have been
the last view that people had of
superman
of course the man who was most affected
by the mustache fiasco was henry cavill
himself
luckily cavill has been a good sport
throughout the whole mustache saga
in 2017 he posted a photo from the set
of mission impossible fallout
and captioned it it is time to finally
set the record straight in this mustache
fiasco
pictured above is not a set on mi6 but
the latest in a series of weapons being
designed by warner brothers and
paramount studios to combat the entity
known as henry cavill's mustache
when the release the snyder cut movement
was building in 2019
cavill didn't say much about it publicly
and when he did he joked that
talking about justice league brought
back painful memories he even told
entertainment reporter jake hamilton
i miss my mustache which is the most
important thing and for me
it was just a harrowing reminder that i
didn't have it anymore and so i just
didn't want to dig that wound any deeper
but now that the snyder cut is out
cavill has returned to the justice
league fold
even posting a message of
congratulations to his director he wrote
on instagram
i couldn't be happier to see your vision
for justice league realized and what a
movie it is
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you